we shall good excellent hello my name is
Scott Alan and most speakers will get on
stage and say hey I'm very happy to be
here but I am genuinely happy to be here
you you might not know just how happy I
am to be anywhere right now yeah I
haven't done the conference for over a
year I mean the last conference last
real public speaking I did was at NDC
Oslo 2018 so I'm very enthusiastic to be
here and I hope I remember to do all the
things that speakers are supposed to do
well find out the talk today is on an
advanced Azure app services and this
talk when I put it together I did I do
the same thing that I do for most of my
technical talks which is this is the
talk I wish someone had done to me or
for me after I had been working with
Azure app services for a little bit and
it would just would have answer to all
my questions and taken away a lot of the
mystery and everything would have been
really good moving forward after that
that's what I'm trying to do with this
talk and it does assume that you've
probably worked with Azure a little bit
maybe you know a little bit about app
services already because I'd really like
to dig into the some of the finer
details but if you have never worked
with Azure app services just the name to
me even when I got started with Azure
was like what is an app service it's
such a amorphous just technical term
like app service as an app is it a
service don't know but just to simplify
it in case you haven't worked with it if
you're if you have an application
doesn't matter how you wrote that
application if it wants to receive HTTP
messages over HTTP or HTTPS app services
can host your application and it doesn't
matter if it's written in Python or Java
or nodejs or assembly language if you
can execute your code on x86 or x64
based architecture you can find a way to
host it inside of Azure app services and
then what would be the point of taking
something and putting it into app
services well the point would be that
app services is a platform so it's not
like you go out and provision a virtual
machine and you have to worry about what
operating system do I have to install do
I have to configure I asked write the
manage patches no it's not
infrastructure as a service it's a
platform so I go to Azure and say please
give me an app service and later when
I'm ready I will deploy my application
or my Web API and to you
or your platform and you'll take care of
everything you'll manage the patches and
the security and and load-balancing and
all sorts of magic so on the scale of
infrastructure as a service to software
as a service app services is definitely
definitely a platform offering from a
juror but that also means that app
services is an abstraction and that's
where things get a little bit tricky
because when you're trying to host your
web application and particularly when
you're trying to figure out how is it
going to perform or something just went
wrong how do i do bug this thing what
are the diagnostic steps I can take
that's when sometimes the abstraction
can get in the way right as developers
we're very used to creating abstractions
and writing methods at high complexity
and App Services is the same way in an
ideal world you would just say dear app
services here's my code now you take it
you run it you send messages to it that
are coming from over the Internet and
you tell me when something goes wrong
and then I'll have to figure out what to
do from there so this talk is really
about digging into the abstraction
because if anything I feel like App
Services is getting more abstracted as
we go forward so just as an example if
you go into the azure portal this is how
you used to create an app service in
Azure or this is how you used to create
an app service plan and notice it's very
specific if you take this plan that
costs at that time and this is old $75 a
month US dollars you'd get one core and
1.75 gigabytes of RAM and these days the
portal looks a little bit different we
don't even talk about CPUs anymore we
talk about 100 total AC use or an AC you
as an azure compute unit so that kind of
leaves everyone wondering I have this
application that runs on a 4 cores 4
core server here in the office what do I
put it into an azure well I can tell you
generally that the first digit there
will indicate how many processors are in
this particular offering so I want 100
total a Cu is a one core machine but not
all processors are equal and that's kind
of why they moved away from telling you
how many cores there are to just telling
you how many computing units there are
because if you go into some of these
premium plans you don't get just any old
and tell processor you get one of the
newer fancy intel xeon processors that
I don't know more transistors more cash
and probably a faster clock cycle so you
know there's a there's a offering in
there that's 210 total AC use because
it's got the you know five percent edge
over the other CPUs that are out there
so things like that are things that are
you know try I'm trying to figure out to
peer behind the abstraction and and take
terminology that Asscher provides like
these different offerings are is what
asher would call a stock keeping unit s1
p1 p2 p2 v2 it's you know it's like
they're offering products on the shelf
of a store when they offer these
different pricing plans for your app
services so hopefully you're gonna find
this interesting and I'll just go ahead
and lay out the agenda so you can figure
out if you want to stick around or not
but what I'd like to do is get behind
the app services abstraction and first
understand some of the physical
characteristics of app services like how
would you actually make this tangible if
I put an application in to add your app
services like what is the actual
hardware that it runs on and I reach out
and touch it
probably not everything's virtual right
but we'll dig into that a little bit
we'll talk about the logical
architecture of how app services works
and what the different components are to
make things work I want to talk give you
some performance tips for Azure app
services and talk about how you do some
Diagnostics but I mean there's a lot of
things that I'm not going to cover so
there's a lot of things that are just
covered so well on channel 9 and
Pluralsight and YouTube and places like
that so I'm not going to go into those
demos that you can find every day I'd
kind of like to think that I'm
presenting something a little bit
different a little bit unique and just
some of the experiences that I've had
that again I wish people had told me
about so those are the different
sections we need to work through let's
look behind the physical curtain so if I
go out and create an app service in
Azure I kind of like to think sometimes
about what is actually physically
happening so you all know that Asscher
has all these data centers spread out
around the world in fact Norway West and
Norway East or two data centers that are
in the planning phase you'll have
physical Azure servers and and azure
buildings here on inside the country
here sometime in the future I don't know
what the
are for those but whenever you so
there's a lot of resources in Azure let
me rephrase that most our resources are
resources that you have to place into a
specific data center into a specific
region and so app services as your
sequel those are resources that I have
to say I want this in East u.s. I might
put it there because I live near the
east us data center so it's close to me
and therefore the latency should be low
where whereas you might create an app
service and put it in West Europe or
ultimately in Norway East one day
because I think that's supposed to be
here around Oslo somewhere and yes so
but what actually happens here's what I
think's interesting I like to place
myself into the role of someone who is
actually managing one of these data
centers so imagine you are managing one
of these data centers and Microsoft
comes to you some of the Microsoft and
says you need to build this data center
and what you have here is nice but you
need to scale it out and expand it to
support five thousand more customers by
next year and you say oh wow so the one
thing you don't do is just go to the
delcom webpage and order five hundred
servers and one thousand power supplies
and so I'm gonna feed a cable and just
hope it all arrives on the right truck
and put it together now you know there's
well-defined blueprints and prophecies
that Azure has to scale dings these
things out and to build them and and
typically every resource type inside of
a sure hasn't associated what they call
scale unit and you'll sometimes hear it
for referred to as a stamp and the way I
like to think of it is I like to think
of it as a blueprint or like a c-sharp
class definition so what happens when we
need to make another object well we take
the we instantiate the class and we
stamp out new objects as or does the
same thing so let's say you need to
support more capacity for more services
well they take the app service class
definition the blueprint and they stamp
out another instance of app services
capacity so what is a stamp like what is
inside one of these scale units which by
the way this is just pointing out inside
of each data center so
West US UK West and so forth there's one
or more scale units that are sort of
controlled by a geo master that knows
where all the different scale units are
so when you talk to as your resource
manager which you haven't used it but
pretty much anything you create inside
of azure has to go through as a resource
manager somehow it doesn't matter if
you're using the portal or PowerShell or
as your CLI something has to tell as
your resource manager please create a
new app service in West us so arm would
talk to geo master which would talk to
one of these scale units so it'll figure
out which one is you know has some
capacity left and that's what happens
but let's actually break down what is
inside of a scale unit so imagine a
scale unit is something that includes
potentially thousands of servers like
thousands of real physical servers that
are sitting inside of this datacenter
how how are the different what are the
different roles that the server's take
on well some amount of this computing
power is dedicated to creating a network
appliance which we would call the front
edie front end load balancer so when an
HTTP request arrives for your service
your your application interested in an
app service it never goes directly into
your app service it first has to come
through the front end load balancer
that's part that's provided by a j''r
and that front end load balancer
actually does SSL termination so it
decrypts everything right there and then
it will forward the request to the
appropriate other piece of hardware that
is inside of that stamp that actually is
running your code so there's some other
physical server ultimately in there
that's has a virtual machine that's
running your code and the front-end load
balancer knows how to direct that
request to you and for people that are
terrified that this thing does SSL
termination we'll talk about that here
in just a bit
but there's some other you know pieces
of infrastructure in every stamp that
gets stamped out so there's some amount
of computing power and storage that's
dedicated to storing your application
settings let's say so yes as your app
services does rely on sequel server
behind the scenes and it relies on other
computers that are what they call
publishers which provide like the FTP
and the FTPS endpoints for people that
like to deploy
in that fashion but then most of this
that we're looking at really all these
white blocks are just what they call the
web workers so these are the servers
that ultimately when you run your app
service you're gonna be running code on
one of those web workers that are just
sitting around waiting for something to
work on
so you could have your app services
deployed here and I show it having six
blocks because maybe your web app
services or your web service is much
more popular than my app service which
only needs a you know one third or yeah
one third of the computing power that
you need but we're all in there together
we're all inside that same stamp right
role and again if the idea of being in a
shared environment terrifies you we'll
talk about that in just a bit but in a
stamp that would be underutilized like
the rest of these blocks are just ready
to go they're ready for you to scale up
or ready for me to scale up
they're just warmed up VMs that are that
are ready to take your code and ready
start receiving requests and ready to
start executing so this is important
just when you're trying to for some
specific scenarios to come up inside of
Azure
it's just important to know about this
architecture and you might be saying
well do I know what stamp I'm on or can
I control what stamp I get deployed into
I don't want to be deployed with you
know this guy's how has your application
service or something like that and the
answer is no you know you provision an
app service so it's gonna pick it
somewhere so my site oh do calm is runs
an ad your app services and I can if I
do an nslookup I'll get back an IP
address that you know if I look up that
IP address it clearly would point to
Microsoft owns that IP address so it's
pointing to something inside of azure
in fact this point that IP address
should point to one of those front end
load balancers that is part of a stamp
somewhere in the east us data center and
if I also do an NSL look up on decoder
web sites net you know because I would
decode coms my custom domain that I
mapped to that IP address but asher
provides this domain to me for free that
maps to the same address once exceed 64
a 23 but notice this one of these
aliases is actually
your web sites thought windows.net
notice the prefix here waz so that's
Windows Azure websites and you know I
used to think oh gosh I'm on one of the
VIP stamps like like someone inside of
azure recognized hey it's cata it's Oda
code let's put them on the very
important person stamp but no that's not
true at all that was me just me
fantasizing VIP would actually just be
virtual IP because in fact because that
same IP is shared by everyone else that
is inside that same stamp so if you go
to the website IP are sorry first of all
if you try to go directly to that IP
address that's basically the front end
load balancer saying sorry I don't know
where to send this HTTP message because
if there's no host in the incoming HTTP
headers the load balancer has to give up
it's like you know I've got all these
sites to manage you're not giving me
enough information to find the one that
you're trying to get to so yes I can
respond to this IP address but I don't
know where to go but if I take that IP
address and plug it into a website like
find your IP neighbors so this is my
again this is the IP for my website oh
do calm there's at least 1100 other
websites on that same stamp and you can
see some of them actually are dotnet or
SharePoint or Microsoft oriented blogger
so there's a number of us out there but
you know this doesn't even include
people that might be fronted by some
other service like CloudFlare or
something like that or people that don't
have custom domains and I'm not even
sure how IP neighbors works or how well
it works but you know if it can find
eleven hundred things I'm sure there's
you know at least eleven hundred and two
out there if not a lot more so I'm not
special I'm just one more my website
there's just one more website that's on
our whole big collection of websites so
that gives you a little bit of an idea
behind the physical curtain which I
think is important to understand if you
want to start doing troubleshooting like
you know you're trying to figure out
what is the IP address and open firewall
ports and things like that you know you
might think you'd be open you you might
think you're opening a firewall port to
just your website but chances are you're
opening
port to a virtual IP address that maps
to thousands of sites and some of them
might be good and some of them might be
bad so logically though what is an app
service just take a moment to describe
those so when you create an app service
in Azure you probably know this but you
have to create also what's known as an
app service plan and the important thing
to understand is that when you create
the app service plan what you're really
doing is you're selecting the
characteristics of the virtual machine
that's going to host your application so
in most cases what you get is a
dedicated VM yes there's tears like this
free tier right here where you actually
you know that's the old-school shared
hosting you're you're gonna be on a
virtual machine with other sites so most
people don't like that option for one
you have to have a website that can run
just using 60 minutes a day of computing
power otherwise you know you've exceeded
your threshold for the day so most of us
are gonna pick something that gives us a
dedicated VM like this one here that has
100 total ACU's 1.75 gigabytes of memory
that's under the dev and test workloads
you can also go for production workloads
and then isolated is interesting because
again if the thought that you're sharing
a front-end load balancer that does SSL
termination and sent off requests into a
pool of workers that you know is
commingling your customers stuff with a
bunch of other people if that thought
terrifies you that's when you go for one
of those isolated plans because the
isolated plan essentially gives you your
own stamp right everything is dedicated
to you so that means that you don't have
to worry about you know if you're in a
if you're building an application in an
industry that's highly regulated has all
sorts of compliance rules you know if
you're working for like PCI compliance
chances are you're going to Li need the
isolated environment that gives you
dedicated resources and no you know none
of this multi-tenant stuff inside of the
stamp but it also means you're gonna pay
a lot more for your app service some of
us have to do that and let's see that's
just an example of one of the production
tiers where that's gonna be a two CPU
virtual machine but it's actually 210
ACU's because it's one of those newer
deep
- series BM so it's gonna host my app
service plan and then the important
thing to understand about a lap service
plan you probably know this already is
first of all whoops
gave it away every app service has to
run on an app service plan because it's
the app service plan that provisions
that virtual hardware that you can
execute on but the important thing to
understand is that you can place
multiple app services on the same app
service plan so that's just like you
know deploying three of your
applications under IAS on Windows Server
but and this is what you want to do
because for nuts and again this might
not be up to date but for $40 a month if
we round it you can have a one core 1.75
gigabytes of memory virtual machine
which may be overkill for just one app
service and I have worked with
development teams where I've gone into
the portal and I've seen you know these
micro service architectures where
they've set up a development environment
where every little service gets its own
app service plan so they be spending a
hundred and twenty dollars in this case
one hundred one hundred and twenty
dollars a month when probably the test
instances were small enough to all point
them to the same app service plan and
conserve some memory because then the
nice thing about that is if you do have
all three of those app services so three
different applications all deployed to
the same app service plan you can scale
them all together and of course app
services gives you gives you the ability
to scale up and down which is change the
app service plan to add more resources
so this would be an example scaling up
to from a basic one plan to a standard
two plan so doubling the amount of
processing power doubling the amount of
memory also standard has a number of
additional features over the basic tier
like the ability to add deployment slots
and so forth and that's the thing to do
if you have a stateful application
sometimes with a stateful application
you get stuck with scaling up and down
that's the only way to do it because the
alternative is typically what you want
to try to do when you need to scale out
to support more customers from that
scale out and in so by default when I
create that be one app service plan I'll
be running one instance of that virtual
machine with my code and that front-end
load balancer will send every request to
my application to that one
Sheen but if I'm busy enough I could
just go into Azure or tell it to auto
scale and I could run five machines or
ten machines or I think I want to say
with the standard plan I think you can
go up to 20 instances and then with the
isolated plans I think you can go to a
hundred instances and that's that's a
lot of computing power if you need to go
beyond that there's some other tricks
you can do but we can talk about those
later this is kind of what you came to
hear I hope anyone yes good at least a
couple nods that's good so one important
characteristic here then is that you
need to decide how many app service
plans you need for your applications and
your services and a lot of times that
could be decided by what are the scaling
characteristics so if you have one
really popular application maybe you
pull that out and put it on its own app
service plan just so it can scale
independently of those other
applications and services that you have
deployed into the cloud so they could be
different entirely different plans from
entirely different pricing tiers if you
if you want but this you know we call
that the density how dense do you pack
your applications all into your app
service plans how many how many how many
of your services and applications can
you put on a single machine before it
you know before it triples it basically
and those are things you just have to
figure out through load testing and so
forth obviously and just one thing to be
aware of in the standard tiers and above
you can create what's known as a
deployment slot I won't go into a
deployment slots a lot but I think the
standard tier supports up to five
deployment slots and deployment slots
are nice because I can do zero downtime
deployment so if I have a new version of
my application to push out I don't have
to immediately overwrite production I
can put it into a deployment slot test
out that deployment slot make sure that
code is the new code is happy inside of
azure and when I'm happy with it
I can tell Azure to swap deployment that
deployment slot with the production slot
and all of a sudden that new code is
executing inside of production and it's
warmed up and it's ready to go and
that's nice but just be aware that
you're the
employment slot that you create so if I
create a staging slot let's say that by
default is on the same app service plan
as production so if you want to do if
you want to create a deployment slot for
load testing obviously that is a problem
because you might as well load test
production right you're on the same
machine create a different app service
plan for your load testing also a lot of
people need to know what the out what
the outbound IP addresses will be so if
your app service is using let's say in
dotnet cords using HTTP client to make
outgoing web service calls and someone
needs to open a firewall for that or
what have you
how do you know what IP address that's
coming from well you just have to add
three or four five or six possible IP
addresses we're not going to give you
just one for the app service but those
are all the IP addresses the traffic
might appear to be coming from when your
app service calls into the outside world
and again you can change characteristics
like that if you go with the isolated
plan you can have complete control with
those isolated plans over your
environment and that's another reason
why people will pay the extraordinary
well I mean it's more expensive than the
standard plans though there's isolated
plans are a lot more expensive they'll
pay that money to have more control more
security avoid the multi-tenant
architecture of the azure stamps and
what's in this VM so if an app's app
service plan creates a VM what does that
VM look like what's inside of it well
you probably know without services you
can create a Windows based app service
in which case currently what you would
get is a virtual machine that has
Windows Server 2016 has ILS installed
and the expectation is that you would
run your application behind IAF's
so most everything you would deploy to a
windows-based machine whether it's a SP
nut core or even no js' it'll run run
behind IES but you can also these days
pick a Linux based app service and what
can be really confusing in the azure
portal is that you get this drop down
list that basically says
and this comes before you make the
choice between Windows or Linux you get
this drop-down list it basically says
what is your runtime stack
do you want to run dotnet core 1 or 2 or
2.2 do you want to run Java do you want
to run no js' so you pick what is the
optimal environment for your application
and but some of these will only work on
windows obviously asp.net 4.7 uses a
stock net framework 4.7 which will only
ever run on Windows so after you make
that selection you'll be running on
Windows and you'll get a Windows VM that
has asp.net 4.7 installed but some of
these options like asp net core 2.2 yeah
you can pick to run that under windows
or you can pick it to run it under linux
and essentially what happens in well
I'll come back to that looks like that
hopefully this is making sense so you
can have a Windows based app service you
can have a Linux based app service and
in those cases where you just have
something that's so extremely different
that you don't want to work with any of
those stacks or you have some special
things you want to install which we'll
talk about here in just a bit you can
just do a container of Beast
app service so you can come up with any
custom docker container that has
whatever software you want installed
you know let's say someone at your
company wrote out their own custom web
server using C++ 10 years ago and you
feel very confident that you want to
expose that on a public IP and do that
through a teener
right they'll build your own custom
container image you tell app services
basically where to grab it from what
container registry it can be a private
container registry it could be a public
container and you're off and running and
then but when I when I say that app
services that you're working with a
virtual machine it's not the kind of
virtual machine that you just RDP into
or that you use secure shell then you go
into and you just customize it from
there you kind of have to be careful
about things yes you can use secure
shell to get into a Linux based app
service this is an example here you can
also use something like apt list and
sorry for the slow font there to see Oh
what is this
what is installed on this machine what
do I have to work with and you'll see
all the usual culprits of we have Bosch
to work with and we have all the
standard libraries and so forth and gzip
and so forth and so on
and what if I want to customize that
stuff well that's also a good case for a
custom container this is a Windows what
Windows would look like whoops where did
we just you into there we go you create
a Windows based app service and open up
a console for you can look at the D
Drive and see hey there's 7-zip that's
installed and there's even things like
some of the visual studio common
components are installed on this machine
there's a program files Program Files
x86 there's two different versions
Python but what I want to talk about is
when you look at this you start to
wonder
and again that's Linux based you'll
notice this Linux based filesystem as a
home directory the windows-based
filesystem has a home directory and you
might look at this and you say okay I
have my application it's running one of
VM how does this filesystem work what
can I do with it can I store files on it
and the answer answer is absolutely
azure app services has this concept of
persisted vials persisted files are
anything that lives in the home folder
so again by default on Linux that saw
slash home on Windows by default it's D
: / home anything that you place into
that folder is gonna stick around
because persisted files actually live
inside of a sure storage so app services
are set up that when they load up that
VM they actually attach as your storage
as a network drive and mount it into the
filesystem so when you write something
into D home
you're not just writing into some local
SSD that's attached to the app service
you're writing into as your storage and
it has it has all the redundancy and all
those great things that means your data
is pretty safe even if there's some
natural catastrophe but it also means
you know a lot of people have come to me
and say hey all I want to do is deploy a
wordpress site into Azure and I don't
want to do anything crazy to have it to
give users the ability to upload files
well it's perfectly
fine for your WordPress site to just
write to the file system save images to
the file system and serve them from
there they're going to be persisted and
you might say but what if I need to
scale up and run three instances you
know so now I have basically three
virtual machines running my WordPress
site it's ok because they're all gonna
map the persistent file location to the
same as your storage location so you
write that file into your website on one
machine all three will see it right away
making some sense thank you for sticking
through to the end of the conference by
the way I know this is uh just the type
of extenuating content that will keep
you awake and send you home with happy
faces right so what happens if you want
to customize this environment what if I
wanted to let's say install some
additional components there on the
windows file system well it's you know
it's a problem because only the files in
persisted bowels stick around and
persisted files does not include Program
Files it does not include been under
Linux so anything I install out to be a
little bit more careful about for the
windows approach is to go into the azure
portal and do a search for extension on
your app service because you'll come to
a thing that allows you to choose an
extension that you want to install and
so for example let's say you want to
install dotnet core 3.0 which currently
is not included out of the box for an
app service it will be once at rtems and
everything is released and been tested
for a while but if you want to install
it now today in preview then you can go
out and install the extension for dotnet
core 3.0 what that'll basically do is
write an XML file into the app service
so that as you're knows every time it
brings this machine a lot it has to make
sure the dotnet core 3 is installed
that's basically what's going to happen
that's how you customize a window in
Windows based app service how do you
customize a Lynda Linux Linux that's
what Windows is becoming right Lindex a
Linux based desktop environment well you
you create a your own container right so
you do it through a docker file so if
you want some crazy web server installed
install it into your docker image but
the doctorat image into a registry and
load that thing into what about for
container so I'll tell you to do that
that's how you
customizes how-do-you-do deployment
Windows app services you can have a
local get what's known as a local get
deployment so essentially if I want to
deploy my application into a
windows-based app service into a
windows-based VM first I would create a
get repository on that Windows app
service that's very easy to do through
the portal or through the command line
and that git repository will live in the
persistent file so when I do a git push
into into that app service those files
will be there and they will stick around
and but you can also pull code from get
from any remote git source you can also
do an FTP deployment FTPS deployment
you know just copy stuff into that home
persisted files folder any way you need
to and of course has your DevOps which I
think you've heard a lot about today it
has ways to push in that ad rep services
but behind the scenes the important part
here is that behind the scenes project
could do which you've probably heard of
has all these hooks into the local git
repository so it knows that you've just
pushed code up and it's going to jump
into action and do what's known as a
deployment and just make sure it can do
a build and run your tasks and copy
files into the right location so they
can start executing behind let's say iis
same thing for a Linux app service you
can choose a local git repository remote
get repository FTP or EFTPS yes the
windows app services actually have some
features that aren't supported by Linux
yet so there's not complete feature
parity there and I didn't include all
the sources here but it's quite possible
that the windows app service also
supports strange things like Dropbox and
onedrive and so forth that I don't think
are on Linux yet but you know not a lot
of us I think don't do a Dropbox
deployment bug and of course if you're
doing your own container putting in app
services again you have complete control
over everything so you can tell as your
app services to monitor a specific
container registry specific image so if
you ever update it in docker hub or
Azure container the azure container
registry app services can say oh there's
a new one let's pull it start it
and that's a very easy deployment what
used to confuse me was how does a sure
AB services if I push my code into it
how does it even know what to do how
does it know what to start like I can
kind of understanding is p.net cuz
asp.net has this long history of having
a bin folder and if I'm pushing up
c-sharp code to the server I can
understand okay it just doesn't compile
and all of a sudden there's a bin folder
and it's under is so I will just load up
a DLL from the bin folder I can kind of
see that but it's still kind of a
mystery to me how does an application
actually launch instead of as your app
services well it turns out that project
could do actually uses a number of
heuristics so again this is this apart
of the abstraction magic of app services
it has a number of heuristics that just
tries to guess what is this person
trying to do if you push up code that
includes a CS proj file should you will
say oh this must be something with
c-sharp so it's gonna try to determine
if it's some old legacy C sharp or or C
sharp for dotnet core right and it's
going to try to run the C sharp is kind
of try to do an MS build or on your
project but let's say you push up
something that includes just a package
Jason then could do will say oh this
must be a node project let's try to do
an NPM install and let's actually look
inside of package Jason to see if
there's a start script specified in
there so it's gonna figure out you're
using javascript I'm gonna try to figure
out how to start your application so it
uses all these heuristics and ultimately
what could you will do whether you're a
SP net or es being a core no js' it's
gonna write out a web config file into
your home folder your home sites folder
where your site is hosted and you if you
want to change something you can
customize that web config file the
project could do rights out and a good
example of that actually would be for
dotnet core when I do a dotnet core from
the CLI if I do dotnet publish you know
it publishes my asp.net core application
and gives me a web doc config because it
assumes I might run under is
historically that's what we've always
done with Microsoft technology in that
web duct and fig bar gets deployed when
you do a publish and it will tell is
inside of your app service what to do
which is essentially run the asp net
core handler to pump requests through to
your dotnet core code what about for
linux again there's many heuristics that
are used let's say you set up a git
repository inside of your app service
and you push up something that includes
an application dot py file so in that
case as your app services will look at
that and say huh looks like Python let's
try to figure out if it's flask or
Django and and do the right thing
depending on on what we're guessing if
it's Ruby you know and and how does it
do this I mean it's very simple
heuristics oh and because it's all open
source
even as your app services itself open
source you can go in and you can see ok
what is the startup logic for when
something is detected as being Ruby and
how does it think it's Ruby well it
might just be looking for an RB file or
a gem file but this is how it starts
your application if it thinks you're
you're pushing up a ruby application
first it's going to see if tests for the
existence of a gem file and if not I
think the logic is if it's not then just
treat treat this as a static site and
serve the files inside otherwise there's
a gem file you know then we have to
restore dependencies and we can use gem
commands and rails commands to start
this application running but you can
completely customize to start up command
so you have some goofy crazy application
that was written by somebody and let's
say Python but they didn't follow any of
the standard conventions because all
these heuristics are based around you
know what are the standard conventions
for a Python application or a node
application or Ruby application if you
don't follow those conventions you can
always set a custom startup coming in
using the azure CLI tell Azure up
services exactly what to do oh that was
just so I remember that if you do write
something in Python
you you get the jewnicorn web server
which you know would be what a lot of
Python developers use for for running
their Python code and of course if
you're writing something that's in a
container
well you specify the entry point in your
docker file so when app services spins
up your container it knows what to do
it's gonna go to that entry point and do
in this case in it container shell run
that shell command so you can start any
process running that you want using your
docker file so then the question might
be what if I have this crazy application
that someone wrote in C++ that listens
for HTTP connections on port 666 for
whatever reason but I want to host that
in an azure app service and put it on a
public IP well you you know set your
entry point so it'll launch whatever
executable was produced when you compile
about C++ code and then if you set the
environment variable or the app server
setting websites port to 666 that's the
way of telling as your app services okay
when I send requests to this particular
container
I'll send report 666 and it will
hopefully give me back a response done
all right moving along let me give you
some quick performance tips so now you
figured out how to deploy your
application you figured out how to tell
a sure how it gets started up what are
some common things that I do for
performance tips HTTP 2 might be the
default now in Azure app services when
you create a new one
anyone know for sure well fin yeah I
can't remember I know I've had app some
app services around forever and I had to
go in and explicitly turn on HTTP
version 2 and I'm not gonna spend a lot
of time on HTTP version 2 you can do the
research to figure out how much nicer it
is and it's much more efficient at how
it utilizes network resources like
sockets and so forth so make sure that
is turned on you can do that in the
azure portal or with the azure CLI it's
just gonna be one of the settings that's
available for your app service another
thing I like to do
is to make sure application request
routing is turned off so remember when
we talked about the app service stamp a
big collection of resources that hosts
your app services that has that
front-end load balancer on it by default
one of the things that front-end load
balancer will do is so it's really more
of a proxy than it is just just a load
balancer when it receives an HTTP
request it's gonna send it to one of
your virtual machines that's running
your code and when your virtual machine
sends a response it by default is going
to add another HTTP header into the
response that is the application request
routing cookie so it's just some unique
identifier so that when that person that
client returns to your app service with
their browser the front-end load
balancer will look at that cookie and
say oh you were running on instance
number two so I'm gonna make sure and
take this request and send it back to
the exact same instance and that's very
useful when you are writing stateful
applications that are doing something
like in-memory session right you want
users coming back to the exact same Ram
exact same virtual machine but these
days most of us are stateless
unfortunately the application and
request routing / affinity cookie is
always on by default so you probably
just want to set it off because that'll
give you that will give you an app
service it's a little more resilient you
know if one of those if you have three
two instances running and one of those
goes down because it fails or one of
them has to be taken offline because it
needs some security update or some patch
if you're not trying to route back to
the same instance you can just failover
real easy to the other instance and the
application looks like it's still up and
running no matter what happens another
performance tip I would have is to keep
the app service always on you know how
iaf just by default that's this thing
where your application is idle for 20
minutes so just spin it down spin down
the worker process which is nice because
that means you might be able to pack
more services into the same machine and
have them running but it's not so good
if you have a customer that comes back
after something is idle and is waiting
for that thing to spin out after their
first request unit
so if you want to avoid cold starts just
go in and set always on to on and you'll
be set another tip is to keep
dependencies close so this is just one
of those lessons I learned working with
a big development team that was sort of
turned loose on a micro service
architecture I was going through and
trying to look through the azure portal
to figure out exactly what everyone had
created and it turned out that um one
developer had created an app service in
East us that was talking to a database
that was in the West US region and I was
sending messages to central us to be
processed by an azure function that was
in Australia or something and I said you
know this is all supposed to be part of
a system a single system why are we
scattered all over the place and we
could have definitely improved latency
if we put these things together so
there's a resource in Azure don't know
if you've ever heard about Azure policy
anyone ever use it no oh
one yeah azure policy sometimes it's
frustrating to work with but basically
you can define policy rules in JSON and
a lot of the azure policy is about
compliance and about adhering to
regulations so it's very easy to write
an azure policy that says all storage
accounts must use encryption at rest and
you can enforce that policy and if
anyone ever creates an azure storage
account and doesn't have the always
encrypted box selected policy fires off
an alert and you go find that person and
you you admonish them there's also an
azure policy rule that basically looks
like this it's very simple JSON but it's
basically a way of saying find any
resource that has a location that is
different than its resource groups
location so assuming you deploy three
different app services into the same
resource group and set it the resource
group to let's say Norway East but then
you have a sequel database in that group
that's in Australia you know that policy
would catch that for you so those things
are hard to find when you're just poking
around in the portal so that's keeping
the Penan C's close another one is keep
your assets close to customers once you
get stuff inside of app services it's
very easy to create a
a sure CDN profile so content delivery
network and the content delivery
networks are are very cheap and can give
you all sorts of features so these
content delivery networks work in
different ways but if I have a lot of
static assets in my app services I I
want to look at creating a content
delivery network and there's two ways to
do it one way is to put my static assets
into blob storage and just point my CDN
profile at blob storage and say you know
someone requests image one jpg go to the
storage account find it send as a user
and the other way is to point the CDN
profile at my app service so it's a way
of saying if someone requests from you
image one jpg and you don't already have
it cached come over here to my app
service and grab it but then then keep
it on your edge servers all around the
world
keep it cast and serve it to customers
really quickly so you can see the the
pricing is really quite cheap and it
talks about terabytes of data another
thing to look at is traffic manager
anyone using traffic manager traffic
manager is useful in a couple different
scenarios so traffic managers basically
a DNS based load balancer so what
happens if I create my app service in
East UASs but then I have a large
customer base in Australia obviously
there will be some natural latency in
those requests so it might be nice if I
created it one of my deployed my app
services into both East US and Australia
so in Europe and everywhere my customers
are but then how do I give my customers
just a single URL that's where I can use
traffic manager and I can program
traffic manager to say look I have these
three deployments one in Australia one
in Europe one in East u.s. so when
someone comes to an DC Oslo calm I want
you to figure out what would be the best
place to send them and return that IP
address so you know is it the IP address
for the stamp in in in Europe or the IP
address for the stamp app service stamp
that was created in the United States
and these are the different routing
methods so just real quick you can do
Geographic routing and you can say
things like all right European customers
stay in the in Europe
all their data goes to a server and a
data center that's also in Europe or you
can do weighted which is quite nice
weighted is actually a nice way of doing
like a bee deployment so I can say I
have to app service deployments I want
you to send 90% of the traffic to that
one but 10% of the traffic over here and
the one over here with that 10% that has
some new features that we just want to
evaluate before we make a change and and
send a hundred percent of the traffic
there those are the types of things you
can do with traffic manager but there's
also recently introduced as your front
door service I have some horrible
screenshots here let me zoom in and make
them even worse potentially but as your
front door service is a little more
sophisticated it does very similar
things you can think of it as a proxy
that can sit in front of your app
services so again let's take this
scenario I have customers in the US and
Europe and Australia I wear my app
services in each location so they're as
close as possible to my customers how do
i route them between them
one answer is traffic manager another
answer is as your front door service as
your front door service though is a lot
more sophisticated it does some of the
same routing and health checks and so
forth but but let me get to the next
slide that kind of compares the two like
which one would you choose so traffic
manager is a DNS based load balancer so
it relies on the DNS system that means
it's cheap it's also very easy to
configure it does do health monitoring
so if I tell tell it about my three app
services on three different continents
it'll occasionally send off HTTP
requests my three deployments and make
sure it gets back a 200 response and if
it doesn't get back a 200 it assumes
that particular deployment is bad or at
offline or something and it could
failover to another app service so this
is also a good way to get to geo
redundancy you know if my deployment in
Australia suddenly sinks into the ocean
then at least we can failover to the
East US or let's say West us sink some
of the oceans I don't know let's not be
so cataclysmic show me traffic manager
does offer different routing methods but
the downside of traffic manager is a
slow failover because it is a DNS based
load balancer so customer launches their
web
browser they say take me to NDC Oslo
calm it returns an IP address then their
browser caches that for five minutes ten
minutes half a day you know meanwhile
something is going wrong on the network
we can no longer reach it it takes a lot
for that to fail over front door service
completely different it's a true proxy
so it's using a technology known as IP
anycast which i had to do a little bit
of research about because i wasn't
keeping up with the lower level
networking standards but IP anycast is
kind of interesting it uses the
underlying infrastructure of tcp/ip
network or IP networking to actually
coordinate with routers to basically say
hey dear router i want to go to this IP
address and the networking
infrastructure can say oh you go over
there or you go over there because you
live in the EU so we're gonna stick you
over there or you go over here because
that's the fastest route for you to
reach and so IP any anycast can feel
over instantly because it's working at
the packet level right we don't have to
wait for a DNS cache timeout we can just
start rerouting stuff right away and
because it's really a true proxy that's
sitting between the client and your app
service wherever it's deployed it can do
intelligent caching it can do what's
called dynamic site acceleration which
is I don't know I think it's such a
bizarre term but that basically means
it'll try to do things like compress
content that comes back from your app
service uncompressed and all sorts of
other network optimization some of which
I don't understand at all there's
something called tcp/ip I forget the
term something splitting I don't know it
sounded very fancy though you can do
that research and figure it out and and
Microsoft dog foods this thing to death
like all the big services like Xbox
services and bings and things like that
they always all use front door service
sitting in front of their servers to
have these feel overs and so forth so
Diagnostics just a few quick words about
Diagnostics all your app service
deployments you have the ability to turn
on application logging and web server
logging and you can set retentions and
hotus and I'm not gonna bore you with
all that stuff because you can find
dozens of tutorials on how to debug an
app service what I want to do is just
call your attention to
few special things that I have found so
the first special thing is inside of the
azure portal when you're looking at an
app service there will be this little
tab that says diagnose and solve
problems and when I initially looked at
this I thought that this is like this is
gonna be like Clippy used to be I see
you're trying to debug something can I
help you with that and then everything
goes downhill from there but it turns
out it turns out this actually has some
really cool useful stuff in here so
let's say you have an app service that
it's just struggling like it's having a
performance problem you can't figure out
why is it CPU or you know or we paging
memory in and out like what is it are we
having does it look like socket
starvation problems right or were you
having problems making tcp/ip
connections to this app service is it
trying to make outgoing calls and not
connecting to our other third party web
services through over TCP I feel like
what is the issue here some of those
things just to back up yes you might be
able to find them out with logging but I
guarantee if you play around in this app
service Diagnostics a little bit you'll
find some pretty cool stuffs for example
I can drill into performance problems
and I can get really nice graphs here
about okay here's my requests and areas
for a particular site and I can see that
most things are green which is good so
there's very few HTTP Ayres server
errors which are colored in red and they
appear to be minimal so that's pretty
good and there does appear to be some
404 x' in there so if I'm worried about
those I can drill into them but notice
the tabs up here I can get sort of the
same level of granularity on CPU usage
and memory usage and then I can also
let's say again talking about tcp/ip
connections let's say there's some sort
of weird starvation problem on facing I
can drill into those things and actually
get it down into the weeds about what's
going on what how many inbound
connections do I have how many outbound
connections is my application trying to
do you know if there's just an
extraordinary number of outbound
connections compared to deliver a last
release maybe someone has done some
sorry trying to talk to you fast now if
there's an extraordinary number of
outbound connections that just seem to
be hanging open perhaps someone made a
change in the way HTTP client factory
was registered you know maybe go check
that there's something else that's cool
inside of there
under app service diagnostic tools and
resources there's an advanced
application restart so what happens if
you determine that you need to trigger
some new behavior in your app service
and the only thing to do is really just
restart it because there's a problem if
you're running multiple instances and
you click the big restart button that
appears in the azure portal that just
shuts everything down so the application
goes offline the advanced application
restart which you can also trigger
programmatically can walk through each
instance and shut it down wait for it to
come back up get online okay now we'll
shut the next one down and shut the next
one down and shut the next one down so
it's kind of a nice orderly progression
of things there and with that we're
getting very close to the end except I
have left a few minutes here for
questions if anyone has questions if you
do you'll have to wave your hand madly
so I can see it through the lights yes
right now um so the way to think of a
deployment slot is think of it like a
completely new app service completely
supper but it's just hosted on the same
app service plan so the question was um
dude does arr affinity and deployment
slots do they conflict anyhow but
deployment slots are like completely
separate app services in a way they're
just on the same app service plan and
they have it but they have a different
URL as the important part so if I set up
like a staging website for OD code I
wouldn't go to oh do calm I go to like
staging dot Oh Dakota dot well as your
web sites dotnet or something if that
makes sense
yeah well I mean that's something so the
question was if I want just 10% of my
users together the staging slot right
that's where I could get a droid traffic
manager or front door service involved
so I would tell them here's one app
service deployment it's also just
happens to be the one behind oh do calm
and here's another app service
deployment just so happens to be the app
service that's behind staging dot ODT Oh
calm and just 10% of the users coming to
OD code calm to send them over to that
staging IP or staging spot instead if
that makes sense yes sir
yes
oh yeah they're armed I went through
that part pretty quick the question was
if you have let's say source code
deployed to github and you wanted to
just sort of automatically appear in app
services when you do a push yeah you can
tell you can configure app services to
look at your github repository and
basically wait for a web hook to fire so
that when you do a push into that
repository when a specific branch it'll
just grab that code and do a build and
you can again there's heuristics used to
generate a build script for you but you
can actually go in and tell as your app
services here is the build script I went
to use you know you can give it a shell
script and tell them exactly what to do
you know yeah it's quite quite useful so
it's a quite useful platform and I'm
gonna hang around for questions but I'll
just leave you with this there was a
famous basketball coach in the United
States he might not have heard of them
because I know basketball especially
college basketball might not be very
popular outside the United States but
his name was Jimmy Valvano he
unfortunately passed away early but he
made a very motivational speech that I
would listen to many months ago and he
said make sure you do three things in
life everyday make sure you learn
something
make sure you laugh at something and
make sure you cry at something so I hope
you learned something and tonight you
can go out and laugh and cry thank you
[Applause]